taking crime off the streets hasn't
stopped it growing behind bars but this
units now searching the cells of HMP
Garf in Lancashire is one of the most
specialist teams being rolled out across
the country risen to combat drugs and
contraband in prisons
we're finally quite a lot of mobile
phones drugs from late paraphernalia it
doesn't finish there we also recovered
drones yes these new officers are the
latest in a series of measures to combat
the growing number of drugs and mobile
phones getting into prisons on top of
rising violence and cuts in staff this
is all a bit by the Justice Secretary to
restore stability there's no one single
answer to the problems of drugs and
violence within our prisons but what
we're announcing today builds on a
number of other measures that we have
taken to ensure that we have prisons
which are law-abiding that don't have
the level of drug use that unfortunately
we have at the moment and help us bring
down the level of violence that we
accept is too high but it's also about
tackling the causes this arts class is
an example of the rehabilitation
education and therapy on offer at HMP Y
Mott it's transformed the lives of some
of the inmates we can't identify due to
the sensitive nature of some of their
crimes
if spice hadn't killed me because we
know that there are deaths linked to
spice it emotionally happened anyway
that's where my name mental health was
if you know the people you can get what
you want really not only is he now in
recovery he's mentoring others staff at
y mo o quite fast identifying the
emotional turmoil I was going through
and all the issues I had or I became
drug free the easier it be actually
became even with other people using and
knowing he was on the wing but critics
say it's the staffing crisis in prisons
is at the root of many of the problems
this is the sex offenders wing that's
around 200 inmates to eight officers
many prisons have struggled with
austerity measures and cuts to staffing
they are now recruiting again but it's
taking time to get fully trained
officers back on the landings and even
then they won't be there in the numbers
that they were prior to austerity while
investment is welcome tackling violence
is still a tall order for prisons with
the ongoing challenge of keeping drugs
out Sally Locke with Sky News Lancashire